meditation is the biggest gift that I  can give anyone and I would say more  than anything it is whatever reason for  Success I've had because on back to the  two U's I'll clarify what I mean is that  in your mind that we think what do you  want and the reality is when you look at  the neuroscience and psychology that  there are different parts of your brain  that want different things  and so in the simplest sense there is  the logical part of the brain that  you're conscious of it's called the  conscious and you think you're being  logical and you want to make those  decisions  and then there's the subliminal below  the limbic system part of the brain  which is the emotional and it's not as  conscious to you but it has more of an  influence on you than really The Logical  one and so they're not aligned and so  meditation helps to deal with the  alignment of those two things